بث قناه متابعه بالجيش الروسي صور قالت
انها الاستهداف ميليشيا فادنر تجمعا لجنود
اوكرانيين في مبنى السكني قرب مدينه بخموت
باقليم دمباس شرقيه اوكرانيا وقالت القناه
وان ميليشيا بادنر قصفت مواقع الجيش
الاوكراني باستخدام قنابل يدويه ترما
بواسطه طائرات مسيره
اعلنت السلطات خيرسون المواليه لروسيا عن
تضرر تضرر 8 منازل سكنيه في مدينه اليوشكا
الخاضعه للسيطره الروسيه جراء قصف مدفع
اوكرانيا وقالت السلطات الروسيه في خرسون
ان القصف المدفعيه الاوكرانيه طال مدينه
نوفويا كخوفك وبلدتي فينوجراد نيو جولايا
ما ادى الى تضرري منازل سكنيه وهنا تحتيه
ينضم الينا من موسكو مراسل الجزيره امين
نادرغامي ومن كيف مراسله الجزيره كاترين
حنا مرحبا بكما نبدا معك امين وهذه الصور
الجديده التي تنشر لي فاجنر الذي يعكسه
ذلك من نشر هذه الصور لهذه الميليشيا في
هذه المنطقه
وتقول قياده فاجنر تحديدا مؤسسها يفقد كما
تؤكد ذلك وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عبر
بياناتها اليوميه على ان تلك القوات تحقق
تقدما ميدانيا في محوري سوليدار وبخموت
وامس فقط كانت الوزاره قد تحدثت عن سيطره
همم جديده على بلده تقع الى شمال من بلده
صول ما يعني ذلك
توسع هجومها وتوسع محور شنها للعمليات
العسكريه على مواقع الجيش الاوكراني في
محور سوليداروا ايضا في جنوب باخم في
محاوله على ما هي بدون الالتفاف على همم
المدينه طبعا همم نشر هذه الصور ياتي في
اطار همم التعامل الاعلامي لنقل لوزاره
الدفاع الروسيه مع
بقى الاخبار الميدانيه همم كانت ايضا قد
نشرت صورا
لاستخدام قوه فاجنر اسلحه متطوره تقوم
بانزال الطائرات المسيره الاوكرانيه ايضا
استهداف تجمعات لها القوات الاوكرانيه
بالمدفعيه الثقيله في محور باخمود اضافه
الى القاء القنابل يدويه عبر طائرات مسيره
فيما يبدو انه تنويع لشكل واليات
الهجمات العسكريه للقوات لقوات تحديدا في
ذلك المحور خاصه وان مؤسس الشركه
كان قبل ايام قد اكد على ان لدى قواته همم
كل الامكانيات بما فيها طائرات عسكريه
خاصه بما فيها مدفعيه خاصه بما فيها وحدات
استطلاع
وجمع للمعلومات طائرات مسيره هذا يعني بان
قوات فاجنر لن الى حد ما تعد قوات قائمه
بذاتها داخل او في اطار طبعا القوات
الروسيه لكن وزاره الدفاع كانت قد اكدت
على انه دائما هناك همم
تعاون بين القوات الروسيه
واضافه الى دعم واسناد من الطيران الجوي
على وجه الخصوص ااا في معاركها الميدانيه
امين اذا هنالك بيان للرئاسه الروسيه
يتحدث عن
العلاقه مع برلين تحديدا على واقع الجدل
الدائره حول تزويد المانيا لاوكرانيا
لدبابات
رغم تصريحات التي كنا قد استمعنا اليها
لوزير الدفاع والذي اكد فيها حتى اللحظه
السماح للدول بالمشاركه والتدريب في تزويد
اوكرانيا لكن الموقف الالماني حتى اللحظه
تحت الدراسه
استخدم
عباره
التسليم المحتمل فهو لم يجزم بان تلك
الدبابات هي في طريقها الى اوكرانيا لكن
قال بانه في حال ما اذا تم تسليم هذه
الدبابات فانها ستكون همم يعني سترخي
بذرالها بشكل سلبي همم وبشكل طبعا همم
يمكن ان يؤدي الى عواقب على العلاقات بين
موسكو وبارلين ووصف العلاقات سواء بين
موسكو وبارلين او بين موسكو وباقي على
العواصم الغربيه خاصه الاعضاء في حلف شمال
الاطلسي بانها في ادنى مستوياتها طبعا هذه
تصريحات تضاف الى تصريحات روسيه سابقه على
اكثر من صعيدوا على اكثر من مستوى طبعا
تحذر همم في الاونه الاخيره من امكانيه
همم انتقال هذا الصراع الى عسكريه المسلحه
بين روسيا وحلف النيته بل مدفيديف وهو
نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن القومي روسي كان قد ذهب الى
ابعد من ذلك حين اعتبر بان خساره روسيا في
حرب تقليديه بدعم غربي بالسلاح وبكل
الوسائل يمكن ان يفتح الباب امام اندلاع
حرب نوويه بين روسيا
والقوه الغربيه الكبرى الان كما سمعنا
اليوم على لسان رئيس هيئه الاركان الروسيه
الروسيه بات ترى هذا التحرك الغربي
المتصاعد لدعم القوات الاوكرانيه على انه
انتقال من حرب هجينه كما قال الى حرب
حقيقيه ومواجهه عسكريه بين روسيا وتلك
الدول
تروكوليبا بان العمل متواصل على مختلف
المستويات لتسريع صدور هذا القرار بخصوص
تزويد كيف بدبابات البارده الالمانيه على
اي مستوى يجري النقاش الان وما هي خطوات
كياب همم في اتجاه تسريع هذا القرار كما
قال كوليبا
مريم من الواضح منذ لحظه انتهاء مؤتمر
رمشتاين قبل ايام على عدم الاتفاق على
تزويد اوكرانيا بسببات لابرد اثنين كان
الموقف الاوكراني متفائلا لن ناحيه ان
الامور تتجه الى قرار في النهايه بتزويد
اوكرانيا بها وزير الخارجيه كما ذكرت
عندما يقول اننا اصبحنا وافقوله همم عند
النصف الاخير من الخطوه الاخيره في مساله
القرار بشان تزويدي اوكرانيا اثنين هذا
يعني ان هناك تفاؤل بالنسبه للمسؤولين
الاخرانيين هنا الامور شكلت اختراقا على
اكثر من مستوى راسيه مع الليونه او التقدم
في الموقف الالماني الى درجه القبول او
السماح بان تجري القوات الاوكرانيه
تدريبات على هذه الدبابات في الدول التي
تمتلك همم منها وايضا في السماح يعني
اعطاء الاذن ربما ربما باعاده تصدير هذه
الدبابات من هذه الدول لا سيما وان هناك
تحالفا كبيرا من الدول التي تمتلك دبابات
لابرد الالمانيه كانت قد ابدت استعدادها
مريم قبل همم قبل ذلك الى ان تسلم
اوكرانيا ان هذه الاسلحه في حال وافقت
المانيا على ذلك الرئيس الاوكراني كذلك
كان طالب المانيا باجابه واضحه بهذا
الخصوص هو طبعا هو قال له قدم ما لديك ولا
تنتظر الاخرين في اشاره الى الموقف
الالماني الذي قال او ربط مساله اعطاء
اوكرانيا دبابات اثنين بالقرار الامريكي
بهذا الشان فيما لو كانت واشنطن ستسلم
اوكرانيا دبابات ابرامز اذا هناك تفاؤل
هناك اختراق بالنسبه للمسؤولين
الاوكرانيين لاسيه
تبدا تدريبات للقوات الاوكرانيه على هذه
الدبابات قريبا وهي التي قالت انها حتى
تورد هذه الدبابات الى اوكرانيا مع او
بدون القرار الم مريم علما ان كل هذا
يتزامى مع التوافق ليس فقط الاوكراني بل
ايضا مع كل حلفاء اوكرانيا على انها تحتاج
فعلا لهذه الدبابات لمواجهه همم القوات
الروسيه همم مع التقارير التي تتوالى على
اكثر من صعيد عن ان الاشهر المقبله سوف
تكون حاسمه وهمم سوف تشهد لحظات المفصليه
في همم تاريخ الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
التي تدخل بعد شهر بالتمام عامها الثاني
مريم شكرا جزيلا لك كاترين حنا من اكياس
وشكرا لك ايضا